I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hello, you guys. Today is a very special day. Yes. It is the last day that Angela will be in her 40s. It is, you guys. I am 49, staring at 50. By the time you guys hear this, I'll be 50. Yeah. That's crazy. You'll be a hot 50 lady. Ooh, hot 50. I was asking you the other day, what does it feel like? Like, what does 50 feel like as
我是珍娜·费舍。而我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一同出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正为你录制《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。大家好。你们好呀。今天是个非常特殊的日子。没错。这是安吉拉在40多岁的最后一天。确实如此，各位。我49岁了，正凝视着50岁。等你们听到这期节目时，我已经50岁了。对啊。这太疯狂了。你将成为一位性感迷人的50岁女士。哦，性感的50岁。我前几天问过你，感觉怎么样？比如，50岁是什么感觉？
you're approaching this milestone birthday? I think I've been in denial because I've just been busy with life and kids and whatnot. But I'm realizing now it feels big. You know what I mean? Like, I realize I'm in a different survey group. Like, they're like, Americans 18 to 35 surveyed. Americans 35 to 45 surveyed. I'm like, oh my God, I'm not in the survey anymore. I'm in the senior citizens surveyed 50 to 75. You're going to get surveyed about all aches and pains and things now, right? You know what? My grandmother lived till 100 and I'll never forget when she was 96. Her and I were hanging out. She was the best. Her name was Lena May and I said, grandmother, you're about to turn 97. How does it feel?
当你迈向这个具有里程碑意义的生日时？我想我一直在逃避，因为我一直在忙于生活、孩子和各种事情。但我现在意识到这感觉很重大。你知道我的意思吗？就像我意识到我被分到了一个不同的调查组。比如，他们说，调查了18到35岁的美国人。调查了35到45岁的美国人。我就想，天哪，我不再属于那个调查组了。我属于50到75岁的老年人调查组了。你现在会开始接到关于各种酸痛和毛病之类事情的调查了吧？你知道吗？我祖母活到了100岁，我永远不会忘记她96岁的时候。我和她在一起。她人最好了。她叫莉娜·梅，我对她说，祖母，你快要97岁了。感觉怎么样？
And she said, well, you know, when I'm sitting down, I feel like I'm 23. It's when I stand up that I feel 97. Oh, that's amazing. Isn't that amazing? And then she said, nothing's broken, but none of it really works. So you guys, I'm very excited today because here I am at work the week of my birthday. And that means I'm getting a birthday cake, right? For the first time ever at work. Sam, do you have it? Is it hiding? I saw your Arby's bag. Is it behind it? Nope. What? Angela? Jenna, you said you had something in your car. Is this a ruse? No. What was in my car is my son's electric guitar that I accidentally brought today. I thought it was code for cake. I thought
她说，嗯，你知道的，当我坐着的时候，我觉得自己像23岁。只有当我站起来的时候，我才觉得自己像97岁。哦，太棒了。是不是很神奇？然后她说，没有什么骨折，但其实没一样部件好使了。所以各位，我今天非常兴奋，因为我刚好在我生日前的一周在上班。这意味着我会得到一个生日蛋糕，对吧？这是我有生以来第一次在上班时过生日。萨姆，你有吗？它藏起来了吗？我看到你的阿比斯餐厅袋子了。它在后面吗？没有。什么？安吉拉？珍娜，你说过你车里有东西。这是个计谋吗？没有。我车里装的是我儿子不小心今天带来的电吉他。我还以为那是蛋糕的暗号呢。我还以为
you were going to get cake this whole time. No, I mean, I can bring you down to the car and you're going to see a red electric guitar in my trunk. When I got here, Lee texted me and I realized I picked him up from guitar last time. I never took it out of the trunk. Oh my God, you guys, do you want a red electric guitar? A weekend, strong, happy birthday on it? No, I think this is perfect. I think I need to finish my forties never getting cake on my birthday. But next year I want a f***ing cake. Okay, I'm going to be 50. It's about f***ing time. Someone gives me a f***ing cake when I'm at work for my f***ing birthday. So 51, do you hear me? Do you hear me? I want
你这一直都打算给我弄个蛋糕呢。不，我的意思是，我可以带你下楼去车里，你就会看到我的后备箱里有一把红色的电吉他。我到这儿的时候，李给我发了短信，我才想起来我上次接他上吉他课时，一直没把它从后备箱拿出来。天哪，你们，想要一把红色的电吉他吗？上面写着“周末，坚强，生日快乐”？不，我觉得这太完美了。我觉得我的40多岁应该在生日这天吃不到蛋糕中结束。但明年我想要个他妈的蛋糕。好吧，我就要50岁了。是时候他妈的来一个了。当我为了我那他妈的生日在上班时，总得有人给我一个他妈的蛋糕吧。所以51岁，你听到没？你听到没？我想要
a cake. Why are you looking directly at me? And now I'm looking at you. Oh boy. And Cassie, I know you're in there somewhere in the zoom. I'm 50. This is what happens when you're 50. You're like, I'm f***ing 50. Give me what I want. Okay, I think we all feel really bad. I would never want you to feel bad ever. Are you messing with me? Lady, I swear it's an electric guitar. I feel like now. I mean, you guys, it was really funny. She was like, I have to run to my car. I know. Sam, it's about the guitar. And I'm like,
一个蛋糕。你为什么直勾勾地看着我？现在我看着你了。噢天哪。还有卡茜，我知道你在那个缩放会议里的某个地方。我50岁了。这就是50岁时会发生的事情。你会想，我他妈的50岁了。把我要的东西给我。好吧，我觉得我们大家心里都挺不是滋味的。我可绝对不想让你觉得不是滋味。你在捉弄我吗？女士，我发誓真的是一把电吉他。我觉得现在。我的意思是，各位，真的太好笑了。她当时说，我得去趟车里。我懂。萨姆，是为了吉他。而我就觉得，
this is code for cake. They're messing with me. Angela, we officially apologize that there is no cake here. I am going to see you tomorrow on your actual birthday to celebrate your actual birthday where you will be getting a cake because I'll be dropping by Gelsen's tomorrow tonight to get it because by God, you're getting a cake. Okay? Okay, all right, done. This week, we are talking about the surplus. It is season five episode 10 written by Jean Stupnitsky and Lee Eisenberg and directed by Paul Feig. Do you want to hear a fun little tidbit about the title?
这是蛋糕的暗号。他们在捉弄我。安吉拉，我们正式为这里没有蛋糕向你道歉。明天在你真正的生日那天，我会去看你，庆祝你真正的生日，到时候你绝对能吃上蛋糕，因为我明天晚上会顺便去吉尔森超市买一个，苍天在上，你一定会吃上蛋糕的。好吗？好的，没问题，就这么定了。本周，我们要聊聊“盈余”。这是第五季第十集，由让·斯图普尼茨基和李·艾森伯格编剧，保罗·费格导演。你想听听关于剧名的一个有趣小花絮吗？
Yes. As you guys know, I am a digital hoarder and every once in a while, it brings me a real nugget. I found an email from Randy Cordray saying that we were tentatively going to be shooting this episode in October of 2008, end of October. And the title, the working title was Spend the Surplus. Oh! Spend the Surplus. And then we just dropped the spend. Okay. So as you watch this, know that we're filming end of October, 2008. I went on a website that tells you whether years past, you guys, the high was 88 degrees. In October. And if you watch us shivering outside, know that that's a fakie shiver.
想啊。如你们所知，我是一个数字囤积狂，偶尔它会给我带来一些真正的宝贝。我找到了一封兰德里·科德里的邮件，上面说我们暂定在2008年10月，也就是10月底拍摄这一集。这个暂定剧名是《花掉盈余》。哦！《花掉盈余》。然后我们把“花掉”两个字去掉了。好吧。所以当你们看这集的时候，要知道我们是在2008年10月底拍摄的。我上了一个网站，它能告诉你往年的天气，伙计们，最高气温居然有88华氏度（约31摄氏度）。在10月份。如果你看到我们在外面瑟瑟发抖，要知道那都是装出来的哆嗦。
Oh, I have some things to say about that when we get there. Okay. I'm going to hit you with a summary. Do it. When the Oscar informs Michael, there is a $4,300 budget surplus that must be spent today or it gets returned and taken out of next year's budget. The office is then divided on what to spend it on, new chairs or a new copier. This creates tension between Jim and Pam who are on opposing sides. Pam is team chairs, Jim is team copier, Andy and Angela visit shrewd farms to discuss their wedding with Dwight. Michael then learns of a third
哦，等我们聊到那儿的时候，我有些话要说。好吧。我来给你讲讲剧情梗概。讲吧。当奥斯卡通知迈克尔，有一笔4300美元的预算盈余必须在今天花掉，否则就要被退回并从明年的预算中扣除时。办公室里的人便分为两派，争论这笔钱该用来买新椅子还是新复印机。这在吉姆和潘之间制造了紧张气氛，他们站在对立的立场上。潘支持椅子队，吉姆支持复印机队，安迪和安吉拉拜访了施鲁特农场，跟德怀特商量他们的婚礼。迈克尔随后得知了盈余的第三种
option for the surplus. He can return it in exchange for a 15% bonus for himself. What will he choose? Well, he doesn't like to make anyone mad, but he also wants the money. Yeah. Hmm. Fast fact number one, the character of Ryan does not appear in this episode. Good catch. Yeah. Remember last week, he told Kelly he was going to go to Thailand? Well, this marks
选择。他可以把它退掉，换取他个人的15%奖金。他会怎么选？嗯，他不想惹任何人生气，但他也想要这笔钱。好吧。嗯。趣味事实一，角色瑞恩没有出现在这一集中。抓得好。对啊。还记得上周吗，他告诉凯莉他要去泰国？嗯，这标志着
his first episode on his vacation and he will be gone for 11 weeks because he was filming in Glorious Basterds, the Quentin Tarantino film. This was such a big deal for BJ. We were so excited. He was working with Brad Pitt. I know. We really hit him up for Brad Pitt stories and he had nothing. He just said he was a nice guy. We're like, come on, give us something. I know. And then he would drop and do like a one-armed push-up.
他开始度蜜假的第一集，他将离开11周，因为他当时在拍昆汀·塔伦蒂诺的电影《无耻混蛋》。这对BJ来说真是件大事。我们太兴奋了。他能和布拉德·皮特一起工作。我知道。我们真的向他打听布拉德·皮特的八卦，结果他什么也没说。他只说他是个好人。我们在想，拜访，给我们透漏点什么呗。我知道。然后他就会俯卧撑做个单臂的。
BJ, we get it. You have to get in good shape. We get it. Mm-hmm. Fast fact number two, our cinematographer for this episode was Matt Sohn. Yeah. So, this actually happened back on business trip because remember Randall Einhorn, our usual cinematographer, directed business trip. So, while he was directing Matt Sohn, who was normally our B-camera operator, stepped in as cinematographer. But this started a stretch where Matt served as our A-camera operator and cinematographer for three weeks
BJ，我们懂了。你得保持好身材。我们懂。嗯-hmm。趣味事实二，我们这一集的摄影师是马特·松。对啊。所以，这其实在《商务之旅》那一集就发生过，因为还记得伦道夫·爱因霍恩，我们平常的摄影师，执导了《商务之旅》。所以，在他执导期间，平时担任我们B组摄像师的马特·松便顶替上来担任摄影师。但这拉开了一段时期，马特担任我们的A组摄像师和摄影师长达三周，
while Randall was doing post-production on his episode of business trip. And so, these last three episodes, that's Matt Sohn, y'all. I love that. Matt Sohn was the best. He is such a hiker. Do you know that? Yeah. Didn't he and David Denman used to hike a bunch? They hike a bunch. I saw him on a hike one time, and I was like sucking air so hard, and he like strode past me with his kid in one of those backpack things. Oh, yeah. And I was like, shoot, he was really in good shape.
而伦道夫当时正在为他的那一集《商务之旅》做后期制作。所以，最后这三集，掌镜的就是马特·松啦。我太喜欢这样了。马特·松人最好。他是个超级徒步爱好者。你知道吗？对啊。他和大卫·邓曼以前经常一起去徒步吗？他们经常徒步。我曾经在一次徒步中碰到过他，当时我累得直喘粗气，而他背着一个那种儿童背篓从我身旁大步流星地走过去。哦，对。然后我就想，天哪，他的体态真是太好了。
He and Randall both were in good shape. I know. But I mean, they need to be because they're lugging those cameras on their shoulders, although now Matt directs. Yes. Now he just hikes for pleasure. Yeah. Fast fact number three, a very big portion of this episode takes place at Shroot Farms.
他和伦道夫两个人的体态都很好。我知道。但我的意思是，他们必须保持好身材，因为他们得把那些摄像机扛在肩膀上，不过现在马特当导演了。是的。现在他纯粹是为了消遣而徒步了。对啊。趣味事实三，这一集很大一部分场景都发生在施鲁特农场。
And Angela, I know you will have a lot to share about that, but to kick things off, you have a location breakdown from Randy Cordray. I sure do. You guys, Randy Cordray is the best. Jenna has shared with you emails that he has sent to us. I reached out to him because I had questions about Shroot Farms. We have shared over the years that there were a few different locations for Shroot Farms, and I just wanted to ask Randy which location it was. And I had a question about the barn. He responded to my email, Jenna, with so many details. It was so wonderful. And photos. I'm going to share. Here we go. Are you ready for Randy Cordray's location breakdown of
而且安吉拉，我知道你有很多关于这方面的分享，但首先，你有一份来自兰德里·科德里的外景地详细介绍。我确实有！各位，兰德里·科德里真是太棒了。珍娜已经跟你们分享过他发给我们的邮件。我联系了他，因为我对施鲁特农场有些疑问。这些年来我们分享过施鲁特农场有几个不同的取景地，我只是想问问兰德里具体是哪一个。而且我对那个谷仓有个疑问。他回复了我的邮件，珍娜，带了这么多的细节。真是太棒了。还有照片。我要分享一下。我们开始吧。你准备好听兰德里·科德里对
Shroot Farms? Yes. These scenes were shot in Newhall at the Disney Ranch. It was originally known as the Golden Oak Ranch. And Jenna, Randy gives us a deep dive on the origin of the Golden Oak Ranch. Lay it on me. He did a deep dive. This is what he said. It was land owned by the famous singing cowboy movie star, Gene Autry. Gene Autry also owned the California Angels baseball team and the Los Angeles news station, KTLA, Channel 5, which was the first TV station on the West Coast. Randy also shared that the Walt Disney Company purchased the
施鲁特农场的外景地详细介绍了没？准备好了。这些场景是在纽霍尔的迪士尼牧场拍摄的。它最初被称为金橡树牧场。珍娜，兰德里为我们深入探讨了金橡树牧场的起源。快告诉我。他做了深入的研究。他是这么说的。这片土地曾属于著名的歌唱牛仔电影明星基因·奥特里。基因·奥特里还拥有加州天使棒球队和洛杉矶新闻台KTLA第五频道，这是西海岸第一家电视台。兰德里还分享说，华特迪士尼公司在1959年收购了这处
property in 1959 and established a movie location on a still working horse and cattle ranch. There's more. He shared that just beyond the boundary of the property to the South, in Placerita Canyon State Park, is the site of the very first gold discovery in California. In 1842, a cow hand named Francisco Lopez was sitting under an oak tree and pulled up some wild onions. He found gold nuggets clinging to the roots. His discovery led to a mini gold rush six years before the more famous discovery of gold at Sutter's Mill. Wait, he pulled onions out of the ground and there was gold clinging to like the onion or the root of the onion?
房产，并在一个仍在运营的马牛牧场上建立了一个电影外景地。还有呢。他分享说，在物业南部边界之外的普拉塞里塔峡谷州立公园，是加州第一次发现黄金的遗址。1842年，一个名叫弗朗西斯科·洛佩斯的牛仔坐在一棵橡树下，拔起了一些野葱。他发现金块紧紧粘在根上。他的发现引发了一场迷你淘金热，比更有名的萨特磨坊发现黄金早了六年。等等，他把野葱从地里拔出来，然后有金子粘在野葱上或者野葱根上？
Yeah. Gold nuggets clinging to the root of this onion. And it happened right there and that is why it's called the Golden Oak Ranch. It should be called the Golden Onion Ranch. He was sitting under an oak tree. It should be called a Golden Oak Onion Ranch. Golden Oak Onion Ranch rolls off the tongue. So there's the background on the origin of the Golden Oak Ranch, which then became the Disney Ranch. So we spent a lot of time at this Disney Ranch filming this episode. There's tons more scenes that didn't make it in. We were there the whole week. This was weird for me, Jenna, because I was the one not in the office and you were there, right?
对啊。金块紧紧粘在这根野葱的根上。事情就发生在那个地方，这就是它被称为金橡树牧场的原因。它应该被称为金洋葱牧场。他当时坐在橡树下。它应该被称为金橡树洋葱牧场。金橡树洋葱牧场听起来还挺顺口的。所以这就是金橡树牧场的起源背景，后来它变成了迪士尼牧场。所以我们在迪士尼牧场花了大量时间拍摄这一集。里面有海量没能播出的场景。我们在那儿呆了整整一周。这对我来说很奇怪，珍娜，因为我是那个不在办公室的人，而你在那儿，对吧？
Yes. When we shot there, the facilities were just limited to a few buildings, a farmhouse, some barns and stables, right? Randy shared with us that in the corner of the ranch, there was a very rundown Western Street that was really in disrepair and it was. It looked like a set that had been forgotten about because no one was making those spaghetti Westerns anymore. It probably had its heyday, but it was really falling apart. But Randy shared that since then, Disney has invested a ton of money and has completely modernized the grounds. He said, I wouldn't even recognize it. There are six state-of-the-art sound stages.
对的。我们去那儿拍摄时，设施仅限于几栋建筑、一个农舍、一些谷仓和马厩，对吧？兰德里跟我们分享说，在牧场的角落里有一条非常破旧的西部老街，真的年久失修，确实如此。它看起来就像一个被遗忘了的布景，因为当时已经没有人拍那些意大利西部片了。它可能曾有过辉煌的时期，但确实在分崩离析。不过兰德里分享说，自那以后，迪士尼投入了巨资，对场地进行了全面现代化改造。他说，我甚至都认不出来了。那里有六个先进的音响舞台。
There's also a fake residential street and a business district. And there's a full feature back lot movie location now. None of that was there when we were there. It was like a rundown old Western set when we were there. I've been there because I was there for the bed and breakfast when Jim and Pam go to stay at Shroop Farms and there was nothing. There was really just these rickety farmhouses and barns that were basically falling apart. Right. And there was only a handful of them and then just sort of fields. Yeah.
还有一个假的住宅区和一个商业区。现在那里有一个功能齐全的外景电影拍摄地。我们去的时候可什么都没有。我们去的时候，它就像个破破烂烂的西部老片布景。我去过那儿，因为吉姆和潘去施鲁特农场住民宿那一集我在现场，当时真的什么都没有。真的只有这些基本上快要散架的摇摇欲坠的农舍和谷仓。没错。而且只有寥寥几栋，剩下的就是各种田野了。对啊。
Well, now it's a full studio. Wow. I know. I asked him a little bit about the barn we filmed in and he said, the very first scene you see of us walking into the barn, that stable was called the Rag Wing Barn. And Randy negotiated a rate to include the horses and mules and the horse that you see in the stalls. Oh. And then the other barn, which was like the fancy barn where Dwight made it to look like
好吧，现在它是一个完整的制片厂了。哇。我知道。我问了他一些关于我们拍摄时的那个谷仓的事，他说，你看到的我们走进谷仓的第一个场景，那个马厩被称为“rag wing”谷仓。兰德里谈判协商了一个包含马匹和骡子的价格，你在马厩里看到的马就是。哦。然后另一个谷仓，就是德怀特把它布置成
a wedding ceremony, that barn was known as Pee Wees because it was the former location used in Paul Rubin's Pee Wees Playhouse. Oh, wow. So they all had names and the actual Shroop Farmhouse was an old farmhouse on the property known as Olivia's. That's really cool. I know. And he sent me pictures of the mules that he took that day and he sent me like the map
婚礼仪式的那个豪华谷仓，那个谷仓被称为“皮威”，因为它是保罗·鲁宾斯的《皮威的剧场》以前使用过的取景地。哦，哇。所以它们都有名字，真正的施鲁特农舍是房产上的一处老农舍，被称为“奥莉维亚”。这真的很酷。我知道。他还发给我他那天拍的骡子的照片，还发给我了
of the location, which it doesn't look anything like that anymore. It's so wild. It's completely different. That's so cool. Thank you, Randy Cordray. I know. He's the best. He really came through.
外景地的地图，现在那里看起来完全不是那个样子了。太疯狂了。完全变了样。太酷了。谢谢你，兰德里·科德里。我知道。他最棒了。他真的很给力。
I know. So listen, should we take a break while I run to the store and buy you a cake and you go to the bathroom and we'll be back to break down this episode? Are you going to go get me a guitar? Yeah. I'm going to go get the guitar out of my car now. All right. Awesome.
我知道。所以听着，我们要不要休息一下，我去商店给你买个蛋糕，你去趟洗手间，然后我们回来继续剖析这一集？你要去给我买把吉他吗？对啊。我现在要去我车里拿吉他。好的。太棒了。
I'm going to need about 20 minutes. Okay. Okay. All right, we are back and Oscar is presenting Michael with the overall budget for the fiscal year. And he is trying to explain that they have a surplus of $4,300. Michael's not quite getting it. He says, explain it to me like I'm eight years old.
我大概需要20分钟。好吧。好吧，我们回来了，奥斯卡正在向迈克尔展示本财政年度的总体预算。他正试图解释说他们有4300美元的预算盈余。迈克尔有点没听懂。他说，用我八岁时的智商给我解释。
Then he says, explain it to me like I'm five. I know. So Oscar does this great lemonade stand analogy. Michael seems like he's getting it. Ultimately in the end, we're not sure he totally got it. No. But Oscar says, you need to spend this money today and you should really spend it on a new copier because we need it.
然后他说，用我五岁时的智商给我解释。我懂。所以奥斯卡打了个很棒的柠檬水摊的比喻。迈克尔看起来好像听懂了。最终结果是，我们不确定他是不是真的听懂了。没有。但奥斯卡说，你今天必须把这笔钱花掉，而且你真的应该把它花在一台新复印机上，因为我们需要它。
We desperately need it. We had a fan question from Lauren Kay. Then Oscar is explaining the surplus to Michael and Michael says, explain it to me like I'm five. There's this great line when Oscar says, then next summer, and Michael says, I'll be six. That made me laugh so hard. So hard. Lauren wanted to know, was that scripted or was it improvised?
我们迫切需要它。我们有一个来自劳伦·K的粉丝提问。然后奥斯卡在向迈克尔解释盈余，迈克尔说，用我五岁时的智商给我解释。当奥斯卡说，然后到了明年夏天，迈克尔说，我才六岁呢，有这么一句绝佳的台词。这把我逗得哈哈大笑。笑死我了。劳伦想知道，那是剧本写好的还是即兴发挥的？
It was scripted. That beat. Steve threw it away so perfectly. It was so cute. It was so innocent. I know. Oh, Michael, well, he's very excited. He knows it's something good, right?
那是剧本写好的。那个节拍。史蒂夫抛梗抛得太完美了。太可爱了。太天真了。我知道。哦，迈克尔，好吧，他非常兴奋。他至少明白这是个好东西，对吧？
He grasped at least that. And he's going to announce to the whole bullpen. Yes. They've got a surplus and he thinks maybe we'll get a new copier. And Pam's like, no, no, no, wait, wait, hold up. We need new chairs. Toby feels like they really need a good air quality inspection for some of the silent killers.
他至少抓住了这一点。他要向整个大办公室宣布了。没错。他们有了一笔盈余，他觉得也许我们可以买台新复印机。而潘却说，不，不，不，等等，等等，等一下。我们需要新椅子。托比觉得他们真的需要对某些无声杀手进行一次好的空气质量检测。
Here's Toby again. He's worried about the radon gas. He's worried about the asbestos. This is the runner that the writers loved for Toby. And this is the scene where we realize that Jim is not team chairs. He wants a copier. It really made me laugh hard when Creed goes, the ball's on you, man. Creed's delivery was so good.
托比又来了。他担心氡气。他担心石棉。这是编剧们给托比安排的经典搞笑连击。这就是我们发现吉姆不是椅子党的场景。他想要复印机。当克里德说，球在你脚上了，老兄，这真的把我逗得大笑。克里德的台词功底太好了。
And Jenna, there was a Pam talking head that would have gone here and it's about her chair and you delivered it from reception. It's a talking head from reception in my chair, standing next to your chair. Oh, what is it? Sam, play it. This is the chair that was here when I was hired. It was crappy then and it's even worse now. To give myself a break, sometimes I go outside and sit on the ground.
而且珍娜，这里本来应该有一个潘的直面镜头，是关于她的椅子的，你是从前台的角度说出来的。这是一个来自前台的直面镜头，坐在我的椅子上，站在你的椅子旁边。哦，是什么？萨姆，放一下。这就是我被雇佣时这里的椅子。当时就很烂，现在更烂了。为了让自己喘口气，有时我甚至会去外面坐在地上。
Oh yeah, I remember that now. That's how bad that chair is. I thought Pam made a really strong argument. She made me want to be team chair because she was like, I make the copies. I'm the one that has to deal with the copier. That should tell you how bad these chairs are. Well, and also everyone would get a new chair, right? Yeah.
哦对，我现在想起来了。那把椅子烂成那样。我觉得潘的论点非常有说服力。她让我很想加入椅子党，因为她说，复印件是我做的。我才是那个不得不和复印机打交道的人。这足以说明这些椅子有多烂了。嗯，而且每个人都能有一把新椅子，对吧？对啊。
So it really is something for everyone. But the other thing I thought was just, what about the copier and the annex? There's another copier. No one wants to walk to the annex. It's icky back there. Well then they should swap them. I know. Maybe Kelly needs to make a lot of copies.
所以这真的是惠及每个人的好事。但我觉得另一件事是，那副楼里的复印机呢？还有另一台复印机。没人愿意走到副楼去。后面太恶心了。那他们应该换一下。我知道。也许凯莉需要复印很多东西。
It feels like there's a simple solution to the copier problem that no one's realizing. Well, Michael's going to digest all of their ideas and see what comes out the other end. Coming up at three minutes 56 seconds is a scene, Jenna, that I didn't think I was going to get through. I didn't think we would have any usable takes. Last week you talked about that clown painting on the wall in Jim's parents' house that you guys could not get through it. You were laughing?
感觉复印机的问题有一个简单的解决方案，但没有人意识到。嗯，迈克尔将消化他们所有的想法，看看最后会蹦出什么结果。接下来的3分钟56秒有一个场景，珍娜，我以为我撑不过去。我以为我们拍不出任何能用的镜头。上周你谈到吉姆父母家墙上那个小丑画像时，你们根本拍不下去。你们一直在笑？
Yes. This scene with Dwight giving directions to Andy and Angela, that was it for me. Ed and I, we could not get through it. Like truly, we could not stop laughing. It's in the bloopers and I think we got to hear it. You know, lady, last week I looked at the bloopers to see if I could find any clown painting outtakes. I couldn't find them, but I did see this.
对啊。德怀特给安迪和安吉拉指路的这一幕，对我来说就是这样。埃德和我，我们根本拍不下去。真的，我们根本停不下来笑。这在NG花絮里，我想我们得听听。你知道吗，女士，上周我看了NG花絮，想看看能不能找到任何小丑画像的花絮。我没找到，但我确实看到了这个。
It is so good. I feel like some of these directions to shrewd farms are a little weird. I mean, like 156 paces from the light red mailbox, make a left. Walk until you hear the beehive and make a right. If you are attacked by territorial crows, I had this really easy. If you smell bear pee, turn the other way. If you smell bear pee at any point, abort, wait in your car for further instructions. What's the problem exactly?
太棒了。我觉得去施鲁特农场的这些路线有点诡异。我的意思是，比如从浅红色邮箱走156步，左转。一直走到你听到蜂箱的声音，右转。如果你遭到领地意识强的乌鸦攻击，我这里有个特别简单的。如果你闻到熊尿味，就往反方向走。如果在任何时候你闻到熊尿味，立刻中止，在车里等待进一步指示。到底有什么问题？
The other thing that's so great about this blooper is that you're hearing all those candy bag alt directions. Yes, because in the script, the only directions were 156 paces from the light red mailbox and then the one about the bear. All the rest are candy bag alts. So were they just, because in the clip you can see that Ed is reading, were they just handing him pieces of paper with like funny directions? They literally did.
这个NG花絮里最棒的另一件事是，你能听到所有那些糖果袋里的备选台词。对啊，因为在剧本里，唯一的路线指示是从浅红色邮箱走156步，然后是关于熊的那条。剩下的全都是糖果袋里的备选。所以他们是不是，因为在片段里你可以看到埃德在读，他们是不是只是拿了一张写着搞笑路线指示的纸给他？他们真的是。
They handed him a whole paper that were extra directions. And that's why he was like, I almost had it. And if you guys watch the bloopers, you'll see that I'm sniffling. I am sniffling because it was so cold on set that day that my nose was running. And I had a tissue in my hand that I was hiding under the table. It was that cold. That used to happen to me all the time my nose would run on set. I know.
他们递给他一整张写着额外路线指示的纸。这就是为什么他说，我差点就成功了。如果你们看NG花絮，你们会看到我在吸鼻涕。我在吸鼻涕，因为那天片场太冷了，我的鼻子一直在流。我手里攥着一张纸巾，把它藏在桌子底下。实在是太冷了。我以前在片场经常这样，我的鼻子会一直流。我知道。
I had my sneezing from the allergies and the runny nose from the cold. Well I rewatched the scene and all I can see is me sniffling and trying not to laugh. Well, you laughed a lot. I did. Well, Jenna, we had a fan question about this scene. Allie Jo H wrote in and said, when Angela and Andy are talking to Dwight, Andy says something about a three-way and it looks like Dwight mouthed something to Angela. Do you remember what he said?
我有过敏引起的打喷嚏，还有寒冷引起的流鼻涕。好吧，我重新看了这一幕，我看到的只有自己在吸鼻涕，拼命忍住不笑。好吧，你笑了很多次。我确实笑了。好吧，珍娜，我们有一个关于这一幕的粉丝提问。阿莉·乔·H写信说，当安吉拉和安迪跟德怀特说话时，安迪说了一些关于三人行的话，看起来德怀特对安吉拉动了动嘴唇。你还记得他说什么了吗？
I can tell you in the script, Rain had this stage direction. It says Dwight rolls his eyes to Angela like, check out the dummy. And Angela doesn't give him anything. So I think Rain was sort of mocking Andy in that moment, like looking at me like, oh, this guy. Coming up, we have a scene that was really, really fun for me. It's the scene in the kitchen between Pam and Jim, where Pam is kind of low-key threatening Jim.
我可以告诉你，在剧本里，雷恩有这样一段舞台指示。上面写着，德怀特向安吉拉翻了个白眼，好像在说“瞧这傻子”。而安吉拉什么也没搭理他。所以我认为雷恩当时有点在嘲笑安迪，就像看着我一样，眼神仿佛在说，“哦，这家伙”。接下来，有一个对我来说非常非常有趣的场景。就是潘和吉姆在厨房里的那场戏，潘在里面有点暗中威胁吉姆。
Yeah. To be on her side. Not low-key. Full-key. Is that an expression? We had a fan question from Jessica Kay. She would very much like us to discuss Pam's, you're on dangerous ground moment saying, quote, I was like, damn, Jenna.
对啊。要站在她这边。不是暗中。是明目张胆。这算是个表达吗？我们有一个来自杰西卡·K的粉丝提问。她非常希望我们讨论一下潘的那句“你踩在危险的边缘”，原话说的是，“我当时想，天哪，珍娜。”
Well, Jessica, we came up with this little moment while we rehearsed the scene. So this idea of Pam going over to Jim and going in for a kiss, but then pulling back, that was something that we did in rehearsal. It was not in the script. And we just were so tickled. You know those moments when you're rehearsing a scene or you're doing a scene and you come up with this idea that just opens it up in this new way? It's so fun, and it's so fun to see everyone else realize it too, because I have to imagine
好吧，杰西卡，我们在排练这场戏的时候想出了这个小桥段。所以潘走向吉姆并凑过去索吻，然后又退开的想法，那是我们在排练时做出来的。剧本里并没有。我们当时觉得太逗了。你知道那些时刻吗，当你正在排练一场戏或正在拍一场戏时，你想出了一个全新的、能让场景豁然开朗的点子？这太有趣了，看到其他人也意识到这一点也太有趣了，因为我可以想象
that when Paul Feig saw it, he was like, oh, yes, you have to do that. Yeah. It was really, really cool. And then we knew we shot this scene first. We were going to mirror it in the tag at the end with Jim. Oh, it's so good. And I love Jim's talking head after where he was like, oh, spooky. You guys were about to head out to Shroop Farms.
当保罗·费格看到它时，他一定会想，哦，是的，你们必须这么做。对啊。真的非常非常酷。然后我们就知道我们先拍了这场戏。我们打算在结尾的彩蛋里用吉姆来呼应它。哦，太棒了。而且我很喜欢吉姆之后的直面镜头，他说，哦，好吓人。你们当时正准备出发去施鲁特农场。
There was a deleted driving scene. It was so good. There's actually two. I'll get to the other one. Wait, there is a scene of you and Andy and Dwight driving in a car together? Two. Oh. They are bookends.
有一个被删掉的开车场景。拍得太棒了。其实有两个。我会讲到另一个。等等，有一个你、安迪和德怀特一起坐在一辆车里的场景？两个。哦。它们是前后呼应的。
One going there, and then one when we leave. Stop it. Yes. The one on the way there, Dwight and Angela get into a fight. Also, Angela's driving. That tracks for me. Angela's driving in her car is filthy. It's like covered in mud.
一个是在去的时候，另一个是我们离开的时候。别闹了。对啊。在去的那场戏里，安吉拉和德怀特在车里吵起来了。而且是安吉拉在开车。这很符合我的作风。安吉拉开的车脏得要命。上面全是泥。
It's so funny. Oh, I know. Is that because maybe she's been going out to Shroop Farms recently? Absolutely. Yeah. So she's driving. Dwight's in the front, and Andy's in the back poking his head through for both scenes. These scenes were so much fun to film.
太搞笑了。哦，我知道。是不是因为她最近可能一直去施鲁特农场？绝对是的。对啊。所以她在开车。德怀特坐在前面，安迪坐在后面，在两个场景里都把头伸到前面来。拍这些场景太好玩了。
On the way there, Angela and Dwight are arguing about centerpieces at the reception. Angela wants a fish bowl with a fish in it. Dwight's like, let's put a piranha in it, and that will kill the fish, and there'll be blood. And she's like, I don't want blood on my wedding day. And then he's like, well, I guess I have to reorder the cake. Oh, no. That's horrible.
在路上的时候，安吉拉和德怀特在争论招待会上的核心装饰品。安吉拉想要一个里面有条鱼的鱼缸。德怀特说，我们放条食人鱼进去吧，这样它会把鱼咬死，就会有血了。而她说，我可不想在我的结婚当天看到血。然后他说，好吧，看来我得重新订蛋糕了。哦，不。这太可怕了。
I know. What is this cake? And Andy's like, you too. That is on the DVD. The other one isn't on the DVD, but I'm going to share it later because it's when they're leaving Shroop Farms. When Dwight is giving Andy and Angela a tour of Shroop Farms, they get into another discussion about, I guess, on theme with blood.
我知道。这到底是什么蛋糕啊？安迪说，你们俩也是。那个片段在DVD上。另一个不在DVD上，但我待会儿会分享它，因为那是他们离开施鲁特农场的时候。当德怀特带着安迪和安吉拉参观施鲁特农场时，他们又开始讨论，我猜，是关于血这个主题的。
They're talking about the slaughter. Do they really have to slaughter the entrees on the day of the wedding? Yeah. I mean, yeah. I know. And Andy gets Dwight to not do it the day of the wedding, and then Andy's like, what's that smell? Oh my gosh.
他们在讨论屠宰的事。他们真的非得在婚礼当天现场屠宰主菜吗？对啊。我是说，对啊。我知道。然后安迪让德怀特不要在婚礼当天屠宰，接着安迪说，什么味儿啊？哦天哪。
I'm so southern. Did you hear that? Smell. What's that smell? It's a vowel before an L. I can't do it. And Angela goes, manure. Get rid of it.
我太有南方口音了。你听到了吗？味儿（Smell）。L音前面是一个元音。我发不出来。然后安吉拉说，是粪肥。把它弄走。
We had a lot of fan questions about the manure. Oh, yeah. Like a lot. Everybody wanted to know, was it real manure? No, it was not. It was made by Phil Shea. That was Phil Shea's job that day, make fakie manure, and he... How did he do it?
我们有很多关于粪肥的粉丝提问。哦，对。非常多。大家都想问，那是真的粪肥吗？不，不是的。那是菲尔·谢伊做的。那是菲尔·谢伊那天的任务，做一块假的粪肥，然后他……他是怎么做的？
He mixed mostly oatmeal, little bit of sand, and some food coloring. Well it looks like manure. It does. Good job, Phil Shea. Lee Eisenberg shared with me that his most vivid memory of shooting this episode was how hot it was at Shroop Farms, and that you guys had to walk around in coats pretending it was cold. I noticed my forehead was glistening.
他把燕麦片、一点点沙子和一些食用色素混合在一起。嗯，看起来确实像粪肥。确实像。干得好，菲尔·谢伊。李·艾森伯格跟我分享说，他对拍摄这一集最深刻的记忆是施鲁特农场有多热，而你们不得不穿着外套到处走，假装很冷。我注意到我的额头在反光。
I think. Yeah. I'm not one to sweat, guys. I'm not a big sweater, because I'm always cold. So if it tells you anything about how hot it was, I was sweating. Also real random side note, sorry if this is an overshare, when we were filming this, I had a five month old, and I would have to go and pump. You were pumping at Shroop Farms?
我觉得。对啊。我可不是那种爱出汗的人，伙计们。我不怎么出汗，因为我总是很冷。所以如果这能向你说明当时有多热的话，那就是我一直在出汗。还有一个很随意的插曲，对不起，如果这算过度分享的话，我们拍摄的时候，我有一个五个月大的孩子，我得去吸奶。你在施鲁特农场吸奶？
I pumped at Shroop Farms. Where? They had, like, first of all, our trailers were a little bit of a car right away, and they just helped me get there, because I would have to go pump. You pumped at Shroop Farms? I pumped at Shroop Farms in the heat. Wow. Things you do for your baby.
我在施鲁特农场吸奶。在哪儿？他们有，首先，我们的房车离得有点远，他们只是帮我到那儿去，因为我得去吸奶。你在施鲁特农场吸奶？我在施鲁特农场的酷暑中吸奶。哇。为了孩子你什么都干得出来。
Back at Dunder Mifflin, Pam is trying to get Michael on her side with the chairs, but she gets interrupted by Oscar, who suddenly wants to go to lunch with Michael. Oh, Oscar knows exactly what he's doing. All Michael ever wants is lunch with the guys, and Jim's in on it. Yeah. Oh, this is a bold move. Oh, yeah. This is Michael's happiest day.
回到邓德米夫林，潘正试图争取迈克尔支持她的椅子方案，但她被奥斯卡打断了，奥斯卡突然想和迈克尔一起吃午饭。哦，奥斯卡太清楚自己在干什么了。迈克尔唯一渴望的就是和男士们一起吃午饭，而吉姆也参与其中。对啊。哦，这步棋走得真大胆。哦，对。这是迈克尔最开心的一天。
Pam says, it is on. It is so on. And then she puts on lipstick, and she tosses her hair. What? What is the outcome of this, just to, like, flirt with Michael and make him feel good? I don't know what she is planning, except maybe just to look at Michael with some happy eyes to pay attention to him laugh at his jokes. But Jim, Michael, and Oscar get back from lunch, and they are hysterically laughing.
潘说，要开始了。这绝对要开始了。然后她涂了口红，甩了甩头发。什么？这么做的结果是什么，就是为了，比如说，对迈克尔撒个娇，让他感觉良好？我不知道她在筹划什么，也许只是带着快乐的眼神看着迈克尔，关注他，为他的笑话捧场。但吉姆、迈克尔和奥斯卡吃完午饭回来了，他们笑得前仰后合。
I mean, they've had the best time. Yeah. I mean, how is Pam going to compete with this? She tries. She goes into his office. She compliments his pants. She compliments his tie. Hot tie guy.
我是说，他们玩得太开心了。对啊。我是说，潘怎么跟这个竞争？她试了。她走进他的办公室。她夸奖他的裤子。她夸奖他的领带。领带型男。
Hot tie guy. Hot tie guy. And I love how excited Michael is to share that he got his tie for $4 and his pants for $9 at TJ Maxx. Oh, my gosh. That reminds me of my mom. Does it? Yes.
领带型男。领带型男。我喜欢迈克尔听到自己这条领带才4美元、裤子才9美元是在TJ Maxx买的时，表现得有多兴奋。哦，天哪。这让我想起了我妈妈。是吗？对啊。
So my mom and my sister, they love to go to the outlets at Lake Ozark, Missouri. All growing up, we would go to this cabin in Lake Ozarks in the summer, and they would head out to the outlets. I'm not a shopper person. I'm like, I'm going to stay back. I'm going to sit on the dock and read a book. Oh, I would be hitting those outlets with them. I know you would.
所以我妈妈和我姐姐，她们特别喜欢去密苏里州奥沙克湖的奥特莱斯。从小到大，我们夏天都会去奥沙克湖的一个木屋度假，她们就会去奥特莱斯。我不是个爱逛街的人。我会说，我要留下来。我要坐在码头上看书。哦，我肯定会跟她们一起去扫货的。我知道你会的。
Especially if there was like one of those pretzel shops, and I could get a pretzel while we shopped. Of course there's a pretzel shop. Come on. Of course. Give me that cinnamon pretzel. Yes. So you know how nowadays they have those haul videos where on YouTube, where people go shopping
尤其是如果有那种卖蝴蝶饼的店，我们逛街的时候我还能买个蝴蝶饼吃的话。当然有蝴蝶饼店了。拜托。肯定的。给我来个肉桂蝴蝶饼。对啊。所以你知道现在他们YouTube上有些那种购物分享视频吗，人们去购物，
and they just take things out of their bag and they show you their haul? H-A-U-L. Yeah. I thought you said, you know those haul videos. I'm like, why do they film themselves walking down a hall? That's what I thought. I thought, who does that? Are they walking through the hall of the store?
然后把东西从袋子里拿出来向你展示他们的战利品？分享（H-A-U-L）。对啊。我以为你说，你知道那些大厅视频吗。我就想，他们为什么把自己走路穿过大厅的过程拍下来？我也是这么想的。我就想，谁会干那种事？他们是在走过商店的大厅吗？
No. Like, haul. Like, here's my haul. Here's what I got. Yes. They would come home and they would get their stuff out of their bags. Yeah. And it was sort of like the haul videos because they would show every item, but part of the
不是。就像，战利品分享（Haul）。比如，这是我的战利品分享。这是我买的东西。对啊。她们会回家，把东西从袋子里拿出来。对啊。这就有点像战利品分享视频，因为她们会展示每一件商品，但展示商品的一部分
showing of the item would have to include the price, how much money they saved. Yeah. So the retail, I got this purse. That retails for $45. I got it for $12. This shirt, this was 70% off at Ralph Lauren. I got it for $12 bucks. So the whole description was always saying the price with the savings.
必须包括价格，以及她们省了多少钱。对啊。所以零售价，我买了这个钱包。零售价是45美元。我12美元就买到了。这件衬衫，拉夫·劳伦打七折。我12美元就拿下了。所以整个介绍过程总是在说价格和省下来的钱。
I think it was a big show for my dad, you know, so that he would feel better about any... Well, your dad loves a deal. He loves a deal. This is what I know about him. Oh, yeah. He wouldn't want my mom to buy a $12 shirt unless she could get it for $7. That's right. You know?
我觉得这对我爸爸来说是一场大戏，你知道的，好让他对任何……嗯，你爸爸最喜欢捡便宜了。他最喜欢捡便宜。这是我了解他的地方。哦，对。他才不愿意让我妈买一件12美元的衬衫，除非她能用7美元买到。就是这样。你知道吗？
So we would always have to make a big show of all the money that was saved. Michael's right there with your family. He sure is. He could get in on it with my mom and my sister. Pam really did lay it on thick. There is a Michael talking head in the script right after all of this, right? He's been taken to lunch. Pam has just complimented him and it didn't make it in and Jenna, I loved it.
所以我们总是得大肆炫耀省下来的所有钱。迈克尔简直跟你家人一模一样。他可真是。他完全可以加入我妈和我姐的行列。潘确实下足了功夫。剧本里在所有这些之后紧接着有一个迈克尔的直面镜头，对吧？他被请去吃午饭了。潘刚夸过他，但那个镜头没被剪进正片里，珍娜，我太喜欢了。
Here it is. Michael's talking head in the script. When people kiss up to you, it's very easy to get an inflated ego. You can start to believe the hype that people are saying about you. I'm not at that point yet, but I'm going to get there. But I'm going to get there. That's pretty amazing. I know.
就是这个。剧本里迈克尔的直面镜头。当人们对你阿谀奉承时，你很容易自我膨胀。你会开始相信别人对你的吹捧。我还没到那个地步，但我快要到了。但我快要到了。这太绝了。我知道。
Back at Shroot Farms, they are inside the farmhouse and Angela and Dwight are arguing over what kind of butter sculpture she should have at the wedding. Lady, this scene was so much longer, it actually started with Andy signing a ton of paperwork because he was actually signing as a witness to the wedding, but he didn't know. Dwight said it was all these insurance forms so that they could get married at Shroot Farms. During this scene, Moe's enters and there's a really awkward moment with Moe's where Angela hisses at him and then Dwight goes, why do you have to do that? It's not necessary.
在施鲁特农场，他们进了农舍，安吉拉和德怀特在争论婚礼上应该摆什么样黄油雕塑。女士，这场戏原本长得多得多，它实际上是以安迪签署一大堆文件开始的，因为他其实是以婚礼证人的身份签字，但他自己并不知道。德怀特说这全是保险表格，这样他们才能在施鲁特农场结婚。在这场戏中，莫斯进来了，莫斯出现了一个非常尴尬的时刻，安吉拉对他嘶嘶叫，然后德怀特说，你为什么非得那样？没必要。
He loves you. And Andy's like, how does he love her, how does he know her? And then Dwight's like, oh, Moe's loves everybody. He's a people person and it's so much longer. And then it ends with us arguing about the butter sculptures. And once again, we could not get through it. We were laughing so hard. It's in the deleted scenes on the DVD.
他是爱你的。安迪就说，他怎么爱她的，他怎么认识她的？然后德怀特就说，哦，莫斯爱所有人。他是个人际交往达人，而且长得多得多。然后以我们争论黄油雕塑结束。再一次，我们根本拍不下去。我们笑得太厉害了。这在DVD的被删镜头里。
I'm going to put it in stories, Jenna, because I had to cover my face. I pull a Mindy. You can see me laughing with my hands over my face. But yes, then they get into this ridiculous argument about the sculpture and that's what made it in the actual episode. We got a fan question from Gabriella T who said, Angela tells Dwight she wants a cat sculpture made out of cow butter for her wedding. I am from Iowa and every year at the Iowa State Fair, there is a cow butter sculpture
我会把它发到快拍里，珍娜，因为我不得不捂住脸。我简直是在致敬曼迪。你可以看到我笑得双手捂脸。不过是的，接着他们就雕塑展开了一场荒谬的争论，这才是最终剪进正片里的内容。我们有一个来自加布里埃拉·T的粉丝提问，她说，安吉拉告诉德怀特她想在婚礼上要一个用牛黄油做成的猫雕塑。我是艾奥瓦人，艾奥瓦州博览会每年都会展出一个
on display. The very first cow butter was sculpted in 1911 and it has grown to be a famous tradition at the Iowa State Fair. Love it. I did a deep dive on cow butter sculptures. I want to hear it. All right. So at the Iowa State Fair every year, they make a life-size cow out of butter.
牛黄油雕塑。第一尊牛黄油雕塑是在1911年雕刻的，它已经发展成为艾奥瓦州博览会上一项著名的传统。太棒了。我对牛黄油雕塑做了一番深入研究。我很想听听。好吧。所以在每年的艾奥瓦州博览会上，他们都会用黄油做一个等比例大小的牛。
A whole cow? Yeah. That's huge. Yeah. It starts with a frame of wood, metal, wire and steel mesh. Okay. And then they add 600 pounds of low-moisture pure cream Iowa butter. It sits in a 40-degree cooler and then layers of butter are applied until it is full-sized.
一整头牛？对啊。那太巨大了。对啊。它从一个木头、金属、电线和钢丝网的框架开始。好的。然后他们加上600磅（约272公斤）低水分纯奶油艾奥瓦黄油。它放在一个40华氏度（约4摄氏度）的冷藏柜里，然后一层一层地涂抹黄油，直到它变成全尺寸。
It measures five and a half feet high and eight feet long. What? Yeah. I saw pictures. It's a cow, but it's butter. I need to see the picture. I'll send it to you. So a real dairy cow weighs like a thousand pounds.
它有五点五英尺（约1.68米）高，八英尺（约2.44米）长。什么？对啊。我看过照片。它是头牛，但它是黄油做的。我得看看照片。我发给你。所以一头真正的奶牛重约一千磅。
Okay. The butter version weighs about 600 pounds. Wow. This butter cow could butter about 19,200 pieces of toast. And this part I'm unsure about, but every year most of the butter from the butter cow is recycled and it can be used for up to 10 years. I hope so. That's a lot of butter.
好的。黄油版的重约600磅。哇。这头黄油牛可以给大约19200片吐司抹黄油。我不确定这部分是不是真的，但每年黄油牛上的大部分黄油都会被回收利用，最多可以使用10年。希望如此。那可真是好大一堆黄油。
It is. Would you not use the recycled cow sculpture butter? Well, I mean, I don't know. Five-second rule. Kind of. Not really. They also do a companion butter sculpture every year. To the cow?
确实。你难道不会介意用回收的牛雕塑黄油吗？嗯，我是说，我不知道。五秒钟规则？差不多吧。其实并没有。他们每年还会做一个配套的黄油雕塑。跟牛配套？
The cow has a buddy? Yes. That stands next to it? Correct. What is it? Well, one year it was Elvis Presley. What? A butter Elvis.
牛还有个伴儿？对的。就立在它旁边？没错。是什么？嗯，有一年是埃尔维斯·普雷斯利。什么？一个黄油猫王。
Elvis? Made out of butter. Oh, my gosh. Another year it was Harry Potter. Oh, get out. Another year they did Star Trek. And in 2018 they did a celebration of the 100th anniversary of John Deere. Was there a tractor?
猫王？用黄油做的。哦，天哪。还有一年是哈利·波特。哦，别逗了。还有一年他们做了《星际迷航》。而在2018年，他们做了一个庆祝约翰迪尔成立100周年的纪念。那里有拖拉机吗？
Yes. Oh, my dad would have loved that. They did a replica of the Waterloo Boy tractor. I took a picture and it's a tractor out of butter next to the cow. Wow. I wonder if you could climb up in it? Probably not. Well, I'm not eating that recycled butter.
Okay. Sorry to interrupt you guys. I got one thing from the start of the podcast. It's done real quick. Okay. It's gotta fix it. Okay. No, it's fine.
Just give me one second. I can repair it. Okay. Oh, my gosh. I knew you guys were gonna do something. something. It's my birthday, Angela! Alright, Angela, how do you feel? This is your first work birthday. You guys so got me. You so got me. I was so surprised. I really thought when I got here that the
guitar was code for cake and then when it wasn't I was like oh well maybe they've just all been busy and okay. I feel bad I went off on that rant. Well what happened Angela was that we were gonna surprise you at the top of the podcast with a cookie-puss cake. A Carvel cookie-puss cake? Yes! But there was a problem that happened. The cake got lost in transit. Poor Cassie has been hiding out here since like 9 30 this morning waiting for this cake delivery. Poor Cassie! By the way this is the first time we've all been in person and it's amazing to see you. Cassie say hi to everyone. Hey everybody! Well I saw a few times you had
to check your phone and text but I thought it was all about the guitar. No it was a panic thread about your cake. Oh no. And then you called us out and we were like no but we had a cake and it's jimba jimba. And also Cassie put together this amazing board for you. It is all of these cards that people sent in because they heard that you did not get your birthday celebrated properly and so people from the Office Ladies Facebook page sent you cards. That is so sweet. That is so sweet. They know because I was real chatty that I never had a cake at work or at school. You guys that is so lovely. Well we could not let you start
your 50s without a proper work birthday. Thank you guys so much. I love every single second. I was truly surprised and I cannot wait to read all of these cards that you guys sent in. It's so lovely. I'm gonna sit down and read every single one. And thank you for my cake! A cake at work! It finally happened! It happened. It happened! Oh my gosh. Well before we did your birthday we were talking about butter sculptures. I know it's really hard you guys. Now I'm like okay we got to work. We still have work to do. I know. We were talking about cat butter sculptures and y'all I googled cat butter sculptures and let me tell you it does not
disappoint. Google image cat butter sculptures. Can I tell you the very first one that came up? Yeah. I'm gonna show it to you. I'm gonna put it in stories. How do I describe this to you guys? This is the first one that came up for me. There's more than one. It is a cat made out of butter pooping butter poop next to a block of butter. Oh my gosh! Yeah I guess it's a thing. There was more than one by different people. What's that about? I don't know. I have to think this is not the cat butter sculpture Angela Martin would want. There's also some majestic cats out there made of butter. It was amazing. People do really weird
things with butter. They do weird things with cats. There's the whole like litter box birthday cake. Have you seen those? Yes. Where it's a cake and it looks like litter and then you make like tootsie rolls into poops. Poops? Yeah. For the cat lover in your life. Put that next to the butter cat pooping butter. Yeah. Happy birthday. Next year. Next year. That's it. That's my cake next year. I want the cat litter box cake. Alright there was also a deleted Andy talking head after the scene because this would have been if you're keeping manure count the second pile of manure he steps in. Yes. It's really funny. You guys he's outside by
the barn hosing off his shoes and he's sobbing and he says this just isn't how I imagined it. There's just so much. It was really funny. That is on the DVD. Oh. Back at the office. Jim is watching Pam struggle with the copier. Everyone's really laying it on thick with Michael. They're making him hot chocolate. They're opening doors for him. It's the best day of his life. It really is. We had a fan question from Stephanie M. At 10 minutes 25 seconds Michael walks into his office and off camera we hear him say I almost choked. Was that a line that was scripted or did Steve Carell actually almost choke on his drink? It was neither.
It was an improvisation. He's doing that as Michael. He was not choking. He's gonna choke later on some tiramisu powder. It's the funniest choking scene I've ever seen. Ever seen. I want to study. I want to study it. I so believed it. At first I thought was that scripted? I had to go look. I had to look too. It was so brilliant and then he did that thing and we're jumping ahead you guys but after two bites that were failed attempts because he's choking he goes for a third and then with his hands he's like no no. He has to stop himself. So good. Dwight is gonna take Angela to a new barn. It's beautiful. It's gorgeous. He's decorated
it like how it will be on her wedding day with chairs and sparkly lights. Yeah and Andy's like hell because he's happy too. Yeah there's a priest and no manure. It's perfect. Dwight is gonna suggest that they sort of role-play the ceremony. He wants Andy to get a bird's-eye view so he says you know you walk her down as if you're her father and she'll marry me but you know so you can see what it looks like. Yes. And you know the priest doesn't speak any English. He only speaks German so they don't know what he's saying and the script it says Angela Martin is moved to tears by this moment. I think because it is really playing out
what's in her true heart which would be what it would be like to marry Dwight. Yeah. We had a fan question from LEB in the scene where Dwight and Angela are getting married at Shroop Farms. Is the minister actually speaking German? Yes. Mm-hmm. All of the German in the scene is accurate. The actor who played the priest was post-boyed and he was cast because he was fluent in German. Mm-hmm. And also because he was comfortable riding horses. Yes because he rides a horse at the end. Randy said that the actor arrived early to set that day so that he could select one of the horses and practice on it. Mm-hmm. Randy also said
that they had to submit a translated version of the priest's script to the NBC legal department of standards and practices because we had to prove that we weren't trying to sneak in any dialogue that would be considered unacceptable to the censors. Mm-hmm. It feels like they didn't trust us. I wonder why. Well, here is the translation. The priest is saying, groom and bride, you come here voluntarily with hearts prepared to receive each other in marriage? Will you love each other? Respect and be loyal to one another until death separates you. Are you ready to fulfill your obligation to raise your
children as Christian parents should? So that is what Dwight and Angela are agreeing to in their marriage vows. I guess Dwight is gonna forego standing in his own grave to marry her just so he can make it happen. Yes because that is truly the shrewd tradition. And would tip off Andy. This whole thing is gonna lead into Angela getting pretty sentimental. Yeah and she realizes I made a mistake with Andy. She says she made a mistake. I know she tells Dwight I picked the wrong guy. Dwight, man, he just messed it up. He does because he gets real arrogant. He's like I know and I took care of it. I fixed it. And he sneakily
had them married without her consent and she does not like that and does not appreciate it. No. He almost had her back. Yeah. In that moment. Yep. But no. No. She's furious with him that he would do such a huge life moment in the sneaky way. We got a fan question from Rebecca M. Does Dwight's secret marriage actually count in the state of Pennsylvania? Or did the writers make this up? Good question. Well, Pennsylvania is actually one of the only states where you can do something called self unite. So Colorado also allows this. According to the American Civil Liberties Union of Pennsylvania, the tradition of self
uniting and marriage dates back to 1681. It has its roots in the state's Quaker population. And because the religious sect does not have any ministers, members of the Quaker faith traditionally self unite in marriage. So these are often referred to as Quaker licenses, but self uniting licenses do not require the applicants to practice any specific religion or any religion at all. So under Pennsylvania marriage law, couples wishing to marry without an officiant can obtain a self uniting license. They can perform their own ceremony. The only rule is there have to be at least two witnesses who are
required to sign the document, which Angela and Andy signed this insurance document. And I guess the priest would have signed something. Yes. In this scenario, the priest and Andy were the witnesses. So this marriage was legal. How about that? This would have led to a delicious deleted car ride home scene. Lady, it's a rough one. It's right up there with a Jan Michael car ride home. All right. This was in the shooting script. It's not on the DVD. It's out there somewhere in the world, you guys. It was so amazing. Angela is driving home, furious, Dwight's in the front passenger seat. Andy is in the back leaning
between the two of them and they start out the car ride and Andy's like, we did it. He's so happy and he starts singing at the top of his lungs this song. That's what he's singing in the backseat. That exact part of the song is in the script. What you just heard is four non-blondes and Angela is so annoyed that Andy is singing so she turns off the radio and Andy keeps singing and comes in with this part. That sounds like Andy to me. Right. Yeah. In the script it says Angela looks like she might drive the car into a tree. Dwight is stealing glances at Angela. Andy
oblivious is singing for non-blondes. Wow. How did you get through that with Ed singing in the backseat though? How did you keep a straight face? I'm telling you we laughed through this whole episode. Every single thing was funny to me. This next scene is the one that I could not get through. I don't know how you did. It's one of my favorite scenes of the whole episode. It's one of my favorite scenes of the whole series. Yes, it's my favorite Hank scene. Oh yeah. So Michael, who can't make a decision, has decided to call Hank from security. Yeah. Who, as he explains, hustled up the stairs because he thought it was an actual
emergency. Well, you know Michael texts people 911 to get their attention. So Hank arrives and I just want to say this was one of those scenes that was set at the reception desk and I'm in the shot and I wanted to edge myself out of the shot because I was ruining it because I was laughing. From the minute Hugh walks in, the minute he takes a few of the candies and starts eating them, I was like, I wouldn't make it. That was an improvisation and the first time he did it, I laughed because it was so brilliant. It's so brilliant. So Michael is gonna ask Hank, what do we do? He makes a big announcement. He's like, listen, Hank is
gonna decide, copier or chairs. And Hank's like, can I see the copier? Yeah. Opens up doors and stuff, looks at it and he's like, now let me see the chair and the room is riveted. They're hanging on his every word. But the scene ends amazing. My favorite is the ending of the scene. My favorite. Well, first of all, he sort of like explains his theory, why the office would need both. There's new copiers, they're amazing. Yeah. Although those chairs, he could not sit in. Yes. And Michael's like so and everyone's waiting and he goes, let me look at the copier again. Michael's like, get out. Get out. Get out. It's so funny. Angela, this was the first
time for Office Ladies that I have watched the show with my kids. Oh, really? Yes. Oh, I watch them all the time with my kids. I know. I know, but my kids are older. I know, I know. It was a pinch and I said, guys, I have to watch this. I have to watch it. You can watch it with me or you can go outside and scooter or something. So I turned it on. First of all, my son was just giggling through the whole thing. He's a little older. So I think he got more of the humor. The humor, yeah. But this moment when he says, let me see the copier again and Michael said, get out. They were dying. And then they started doing it as a bit. It was so good. It was so fun. Gosh, I'm so excited
as my kids get older for them to discover it. Yeah. I know. Well, my kids love the office and, you know, every once in a while, we'll watch an episode and Isabelle will go, mom, because Angela Martin is so mean. And you know, Jack, my stepson loves Office Ladies. I know. Whenever I see him, he'll tell me some fun thing he heard on Office Ladies, which I love. I know. He was like, I'm so excited that you guys are going to talk to Steven Merchant. I love that they watched it with you. So we kind of already talked about this scene where Michael is eating tiramisu while talking to David Wallace. But what we did not mention is that David gives him some new information. Yeah. He's like any
boss that comes in under budget gets 15% of that surplus. Michael whips out his calculator and he discovers that means he could get $645. Do you know how far that can go at Burlington Co. Factory? You're literally a king. Yeah. If you walk in there with $645. Well, Michael's got dollar signs now on the brain. Michael walks out of his office and he announces that he doesn't think they need a new copier or new chairs. He demonstrates that the copier works perfectly and then he's going to demonstrate how great Pam's chair really is. Two things. First of all, in the bloopers, Jenna, when Steve tries to use the copier, that copier actually was really crappy. It was awful. It was really old and crappy and half the
time would not work in real life. When we needed it to. When we needed it to. And it would eat paper. It would like make noises and he says, this copier works fine and he hits the button and in real life it went. And you guys all started laughing. It was so funny. Paul Feig sent us an audio clip because this was one of his favorite memories from shooting this episode. Here's what he had to say. There were so many fun things in season five. But weirdly, one of my favorite episodes that we did was The Surplus. And it's an episode that people don't talk about as much. And I just think it's got some of the funniest stuff in it. I think I laughed harder during that. My favorite gag, one of
my favorite gags that I ever got to do on the office was when Michael's trying to convince everybody that they don't need a new copier and all the chairs are good. And we had that gag, Jenna, where he comes behind the desk and just tries to prove that your chair's not broken. And I had them rig up this thing because the whole joke is, he sits on your chair and it just sinks down below the desk. And so worked really hard to have them rig this chair up that sunk so slowly that Steve just got in it and he's just talking like, see, there's nothing wrong with this. And you just, it takes you a few seconds to realize that he's just very slowly sinking down behind the desk. And then just Steve just destroyed
me one. Not only is he down low, but he won't admit it. And then the way he has to stand up is like, hey, I like to take such effort for him to get out of the very low chair. So that was a real favorite gag of mine. Well, every time he would get out of the chair, he would make some other different grunting noise and it would do me in. If you watch my face in the scene, I have this really like over exaggerated furrowed brow. I was having to make a very strong acting choice because I couldn't do blank. I couldn't do it. I had to do something with my face. Right. I had completely forgotten about this scene. And when I rewatched it, because it's
been a long time since I've seen this episode. And when I rewatched it this week, I was like, watching it and I was like, wait, is this chair sinking? Oh my God, it's chair sinking. It was so funny. It was so funny and it's so subtle. It's such a small moment. And in order to make it work, I could not be sitting on the chair at the beginning of the scene. So it looks like I'm sitting and then he comes over and takes my seat. Did you have to squat? I had to squat. Psy, work out.
And hold my butt and hover. And you can tell a little bit because in order to do it, I kind of had to like, you know, really like spread my legs to get like a good solid squat on the chair above the chair. Yeah. It's like going to the bathroom in a porta potty. Yes. Halfway through your pee, like your legs start shaking. You're like, oh crap, I need to work out more. This was a workout day for me.
Oh my gosh. That's how we pulled off that gag. Also in this moment, everyone starts to realize that Michael knows about the bonus. Oscar calls him out. He's like, I think you know. And he's like, what's 15% of 4,300? That's the surplus. And Michael immediately goes $645. And he's like, why'd you say dollars? And he's like, that's just how my brain works. Yeah.
And Kevin goes, he's a genius. But then Oscar says, okay, Michael, what's 15% of 200? And then Michael doesn't know. That little bit of Kevin thinking that Michael is a math genius in that moment. Paul Feek said him and his wife, Lori, love that little bit and that they do that bit that like, if someone says something, they'll be like, he's a genius. Oh, they do Kevin. That's their little bit.
All of this leads to a very big smooch. Andy and Dwight and Angela have returned to the office. Yeah. And once you piss Angela off, she's going to dig in her heels. Mm-hmm. And she's going to make a very public show to Dwight that she has chosen, once again, Andy over him. Yeah. So Andy is eating a tuna sandwich that he's real proud of. He wants Jim to know,
tuna, I'm eating tuna. And Angela marches across the bullpen and kisses him. He's leaning back in his chair. She lays on his lap and grabs his face. Do you know what the stage direction was for this kiss? Read it. Angela kisses Andy with a passion we haven't seen since Jim and Pam in Casino Night. I know. I read that. We had a lot of questions about this scene though, Angela.
Oh, well, I bet I have some stories for you. Dory C and Amanda C both want to know, did Ed actually have tuna in his mouth when you kissed him? Yes. Oh! That was part of the joke. Lee and Jean, who wrote this episode, they thought it would be very funny if Andy was eating something gross when I had to go kiss him. And that's why he has that line, look, tuna, tuna fish sandwich, just like you. Because they really
wanted to make sure the audience knew he was eating this smelly tuna fish sandwich. And I was supposed to go over and we're supposed to have this huge kiss while he has tuna fish in his mouth. And then you see me get up and I wipe my mouth. Yeah. Ed was so sweet. And he said, Angela, I am going to hold my lips together. I'm going to take a deep breath. I'm going to take a bite of the tuna fish sandwich and then I am going to purse my lips together and not open them at all because I don't want you to get any of this tuna
fish. I was like, oh, Ed, that is so sweet. And so we literally did, you know, what we call like, grandparent kissing. You're just like, mm, mm. He did not open his lips for a second. And they really wanted me to sort of have this long kiss, right? Yeah. And I was in control. I was the one that grabbed him and then I was the one that released him. And I remember one time they were like, can you sell it a little bit more? Can you make it a little bit bigger of a moment? And poor Ed, the minute we broke apart, he went, oh,
because he hadn't been breathing. He was holding his breath with a big bite of tuna fish sandwich in his mouth. Here's my question. Couldn't Phil have made fake tuna fish? I don't know. Would that have been better? I don't know. I mean, what could it have been? I don't know. You could have maybe, I mean, whatever it is, it's gonna be mayo based, but it could have been chopped up chicken.
That's still gross. I would have bought it, but it's not as stinky. It's true. But Ed was a true gentleman. He kept his mouth closed. I didn't get any tuna fish on my person. And you guys, when my character stands up and says, and now I have a legal issue to attend to, I actually had a big speech that got deleted. Really? Yes. And I was so nervous to do it because it was one of those moments where I had a speech in the bullpen with everyone looking at me. This is how the script described everyone
reacting to the kiss and my speech after. Everyone watches with disgust. Dwight's eyes go wide. Angela pulls away. Andy continues to chew and then swallows the bite. Angela wipes her mouth. And here's the speech. I would marry you during an earthquake in the middle of a tornado. I would marry you in the front row of an Elton John concert. I don't care how terrible a place it is. I just want to be with you. Now I have a legal matter to clear up. Not an Elton John fan. Clearly.
Clearly not. But yeah, so I had that speech I had to do and they gave me a few alts, you know, and I was really nervous, but all that made it in was now I have a legal matter to clear up. And I actually think that was a good edit because the kiss was enough, right? That was enough of like shoving it in Dwight's face. I didn't need to make this speech. But yes, no tuna. Thank you, Ed. Very different from a kiss with Rain who actually was eating tuna in real life backstage for no reason at all, knowing he is kissing. Yes, that are drinking coffee while eating like an everything bagel that had onions on
it. Yeah. Different. Very different. Approaches. This whole copier chair thing is going to wrap up. The employees are going to confront Michael in his office and he basically tells them, you know what? You decide. You all have to agree or else I'm taking the bonus because he kind of thinks like there's no way that's going to happen, right? Of course he thinks there's no way. He thinks he got him. They very quickly decide to get the chairs. He was like, son of a...
He actually says mother. Yeah, he does. F. Was he putting sugar in his diet coat? He was. Yeah, he wanted to sweeten it. Oh, my Lord. The whole thing kind of ends with Michael. He has a talking head. He wants you to know what he learned. What did he learn? He learned that his team is faster at making a decision than he thought. He also learned that you should never buy a fur coat with a credit card until you actually have the money to pay for it.
Michael, why in the world are you buying a fur coat? You're never going to wear it. It's ridiculous looking. Yes. He's just like a kid that gets money and doesn't know what to do with it. In his mind, that's, I don't know, fancy luxury or something. Yeah. Fancy people have those or something. I guess so. The third thing he learned is that people think it's cool to throw fake blood on you as you leave Burlington Coat Factory. So he has a ruined fur coat that he bought on credit.
That he can't afford. Yeah. That's how his day ended. Yeah. Jim and Pam's day is going to end with a truce, but oh, can you make me three copies of this? I'm just kidding. I need four. Is this Jim Sass? Oh, that's some Jim Sass. I have one final question for you.
Yes. Is it Team Copier or Team Chair? Team Chair. What would you be? Team Chair. Yeah. Team Copier doesn't even make any sense to me, frankly. I mean, I would just suffer through a crappy machine. How many times have you worked in
an office where either the fax machine, I know I'm a dinosaur, or the copier didn't work great, but a chair, that's like your tailbone. That's your spine. That's your butt. Is anyone Team Copier? Can we put a poll in Office Ladies Pod today? Yes. I'm so curious. I'll put a poll and we'll see. We want to see. Well, you guys, that was Spend the Surplus and also Angela's birthday. Hey!
Woo-hoo-hoo-hoo! Yay, Angela. Yay. Next time I talk to you guys, I'll be American Survey 50 to 75. That'll be me. See you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is
Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of StitcherPremium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.